in one of the main squares in central
Baghdad police and protesters confront
each other it began in the early hours
of Monday as protesters tried to block
the road leading to the square they want
a change of government and accused the
current one of corruption a call had
gone out to protesters to block main
roads in Baghdad and major highways in
the south cutting off access police used
live ammunition and fire tear gas in an
attempt to disperse the crowds in the
capital but a standoff ensued lasting
several hours angry Iraqis are
determined to get their message across
the idea isn't just blocking the roads
all the people here are frustrated so we
make noise here to make sure that we are
heard about the shawarma days did you
morning what I heard for months no one
has listened to our demands they're
killing us
it's just bloodshed throughout the day
tooktook three-wheelers have been
ferrying tear gas victims to makeshift
hospitals like this one I went to tyronn
square in Baghdad people wanted me to
help them I was also attacked by tear
gas I fell down the security forces have
been using tear gas and live ammunition
Iraq's National Security Council has
authorized the arrests of protesters but
so far that had little impact on the
movement there wasn't the same level of
violence elsewhere in the country as
there was in Baghdad and the road blocks
in the south the protestors considered
their success the real question for the
protest movement is where do you go from
here once you've started blocking off
roads in the south of the country
effectively cutting off the South from
the rest of the country where do you
escalate your demands aren't being
listened to and that's really angry the
protest movement now it really remains
to be seen whether the blockade of the
roads is going to work and whether the
government will listen as a result of it
imran khan al jazeera baghdad all right
let's speak to another of our
correspondents in Baghdad now Osama bin
Javed Osama it's night time now just
bring us up to speed with the latest
first as far as casualties after today's
demonstrations
hopefully until a few hours ago we saw
protesters defiance did it completely
undeterred with all of the violence we
saw those three wheelers pulling bins
towards the front lines as they called
them they've set up barricades and
they're telling everyone that they're
not going to leave until their demands
are met this is the first night that
we're seeing them coming out in force
again after weeks of our lull in the
protest especially after the tensions
flared up between the United States and
Iran and ahead of a planned rally by
government linked parties as well
protesters have been facing tear gas
rubber coated bullets and some have been
saying that live munitions have been
used through the day we've been they've
been sending us videos graphic videos of
their rules how people have been killed
how people have been wounded at these
two bodies we've seen we saw one funeral
happening in Tehran Square as we were
there and protesters are saying that the
government is back to its tactics as it
was using before but it is not going to
make them stop one protesters one
protester told us that he has been
coming here since October the first and
he's going to continue to come there
until the government either meets the
protesters demands which are provide
them jobs better facilities health care
make sure that the people who are ruling
them have integrity and honesty and
nobody who is be who will be nominated
by the government should be part of the
political elite because they think
everybody who's is part of the Iraqi
government and opposition parties is
corrupt and the protesters Osama have
been trying to block roads to the south
what impact is that having and what's
likely to happen next given the
government hasn't responded to the
protesters demands
well at least nine people have been
arrested for doing just that in Baghdad
14 policemen have been injured so it has
been a very tough day for all sides
because the protesters said that they
are going to make sure that the
government hears them and it is evident
that the people living in not just
Baghdad but across the country have felt
the same size and scale of these
protests specially in the south where
many areas there was a provincial day
off people could not go to work many
people had been stranded for hours on
these highways which were blocked and
that is that is what the protesters
wanted to tell the government that they
are want the government to take notice
they say the government has been
procrastinating in the gap there they
did manage to remove the government
right now Iraq is being ruled by an
interim government but they say that is
not enough it has been weeks since
they've heard the government come up
with names they who they want and they
have been rejecting the names that the
government has been putting forward so
it is going by the looks of it going to
escalate protesters have been calling
others to come and join them telling
people who were there that they they
were they will not be deterred by this
they're going to hold their positions
meet to make sure that 480 odd people
who've died and more than 25,000 people
who've been wounded did not do all of
that in vain thank you for that update
Osama bin Javed live for us in Baghdad